après avoir connu un sommet à la mi mars
'l'indice du dollar américain se négocie
actuellement à son plus bas niveau
depuis plus de deux ans pourquoi le
billet vert perd du terrain
comment on peut expliquer un appétit
plus modérées de la part des
investisseurs pour cette devise qui est
pourtant habituellement une valeur
refuge
on en discute avec hendrix vachon il est
économiste chez desjardins merci d'être
là monsieur vachon
bonjour alors d'entrée de jeu nous avait
préparé un graphique ça va nous aider à
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est un graphique qui montre les
variations du dollar américain depuis
quelques mois ce qu'on va voir
précisément sur ce graphique là c'est la
valeur du dollar américain
comparativement un panier de devises
internationales la livre dollar canadien
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir sur ce
graphique
qu'est ce que confirme la courbe en fait
ce qu'on voit à peu près depuis la mi
mai il ya une tendance nette à la base
pour le dollar américain qui s'est faite
essentiellement en deux phases la vente
l'animé puis de la première semaine de
juin a eu comme première phase de
dépréciation contre les principales
devises dont l'euro la livre et d'un
canadien ayant soudain publique tard en
juillet salaire pris 7,1 phase de
dépréciation la concorde essentiellement
avec une publication de plusieurs
données souvent plus optimiste que
qu'est ce que t'as tendu des bonnes
nouvelles on voit une reprise à kauda
vick qui est quand même assez vigoureuse
après la forte baisse dans plusieurs
indices d'activité on a vu des rebonds
importants
donc ça contribuer à baisser le niveau
de vie qui tu dors générale sur les
marchés dans american le mans s'est
reconnue comme une valeur refuge donc
quand les gens voient son camp qu'il
inquiétude est élevé par américaine à
être populaire et en a acheté
massivement
mais quand c'est le contraire qui se
produit donc en que les gens reprennent
confiance
alors on voit que d'un certain délai
semences d'américains s'accordent assez
bien qu'est-ce qu'on a observée puis par
là aussi d'autres explications
c'est ce qui est quand même lien par
exemple avec la résurgence du virus aux
états unis ou encore la gesse
de la crise par de notre chance mais
c'est ça oui les données économiques ont
été bonnes
par contre c'est pas tous les risques
qui ont été évincés là on avait
mentionné la cave il des résurgences
décote coville comptait plus important
aux états unis rapport beaucoup d'autres
pays donc c'est certain que ça ça peut
avoir pesé dans la balance
donc ça pas besoin de 20 pieds
défavorables ces pistes dollar américain
par rapport à ça l'admistration autres
on parle essentiellement de retour du
protectionnisme américain sur ce qu'on
avait vu en 2019 c'est que souvent
autour protectionniste du côté américain
sava avantage satiriste tout apprécié de
leurs l'amérique donc le polo le lamer
explications par contre on peut voir des
inquiétudes commencent à apparaître
par rapport à la politique monétaire des
banques centrales est entre autres la
fidh
je m'explique c'est que si on anticipe
de l'inflation si on passe les bras
central en fonds auto donc l'économie va
vivre semble aller mieux les politiques
accommodantes très longtemps
manifestants commencent à inquiéter
beaucoup d'inflation va te rejoindre des
dévaluations compétitives vis-à-vis des
devises
non ce ça coûte poser aussi dans la
balance de peser négativement alors
amérique ouais plusieurs incertitudes ou
simon pense à l'endettement qui est
élevé il ya les élections qui s'en
viennent
est ce que la foule à la baisse du
dollar américain ça va se poursuivre
mais les niveaux des niveaux des devises
au ski sont présentement je me retirais
aulas 100 m jama plus haut que qu'est-ce
que je m'attendais d'ici la fin de
l'année
par contre il faut pas oublier que les
mots qu'on vient de connaître l'heure en
termes de données économiques dès qu'on
a eu le la partie facile dans la dans la
reprise économique
donc l'on le confinement était très
sévère au printemps on a des conflits
n'est pas mal donc on a eu un retour
important des consommateurs et même un
peu partout les nombreux ouverture masse
et d'entreprises là par contre le reste
debout
boulo chemin qui reste à parcourir va
être beaucoup plus difficile et c'est
pas impossible aussi qu'on a une
résurgence des codes qu'ovide durant les
mois d'octobre novembre des 106 au pas
de vaccin donc je m'attendrais ce qu'on
ait pas d un certain retour de
l'inquiétude est pas une forte
inquiétude comme on a eu quand même une
certaine inquiétude qui revient d'ici la
fin d'année donc créé pas prêt à dire
que c'est terminé et que donc je serais
pas surpris qu'on voit qu'on veut voir
la fin de l'année voyez quand même des
experts dans les derniers jours des
économistes qui se demandaient ce que le
dollar américain pourrait même perdre
son statut de monnaie de réserve
mondiale rapide ou d'abord ce qu'on
entend par là mais moi de réserve c'est
quand on regarde les réserves des
banques centrales ont des réserves en
devises étrangères centre raison là mais
ces réserves le on connaît leur
constitution et on voit que le danger
qu'un y est dominant ses réserves c'est
plus de 60% les réserves sont en dollars
américains
c'est ce que tu as déjà été plus haut
que 60% leur hausse s'est auto de 20%
relativement stable le yen à augmenter
un petit peu mais je dirais pour que le
dos mais quand perdre son statut de
réserve internationale de chemin fer
s'est pas wintek il neige en tendance
art by dans la coop au son des réserves
pour le grand américain
mon bac est encore très dominant donc
c'est pas demain la veille je dirais que
le dollar américain deviendra qu'une
monnaie la monnaie internationale
s'appellera remplaçant puis grosses
écuries sapera d'enrique impopulaire
pourquoi parce quelqu'un qu'on va
acheter des objets des deux sites en
dollars américains il y en a plein de la
dernière qui est à notre place des
marchés qui sont très très profond donc
c'est pour ceux qui incarnent à un
intérêt de l'américain si tout le monde
la planète
ce que voulaient au canada tandis que
les obligations américaines n'étaient
pas nés quand y'en a beaucoup donc c'est
un gros marché capable de fournir
beaucoup les besoins des investisseurs
internationaux
le rôle problème c'est qu'aucune crise
et de manas que le roux éclate donc ce
n'était pas aussi
le candidat idéal mais qui parle la
monnaie chinoise d'amendé chinois encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire avant d'être
totalement libéralisé et puis de
ressembler vraiment des monnaies comme
le dollar canadien et le dollar des
ricains on va conclure sur le dollar
canadien justement dont il ya une petite
appréciation récemment on tourne autour
de 75 cents américains on s'en va ou
pour la devise canadienne
bien honnêtement qu'est encore plus
d'appréciation d'or canadien fera que
les choses continuent d'aller mieux que
prévu et j'ai l'impression que ce soit
pas le cas je pense comme je suis en
effet de plus le plus facile parmi les
prochains mois vont commencer et un peu
plus d'ici tu pas impossible qu'on a dit
l'urgence de kossi de kovy de même au
canada
donc je retrace à des peines de dix
stabilité ou même légère dépréciation la
fin de l'année quelque part en santé
trail 75,9 promène la fourchette où on
voit si celui-ci la fin d'année bon
c'est noté merci pour vos explications
monsieur vachon plaisir